Hoy quiero hablarles de...
de mundos virtuales, planetas digitales, de la web 3D, del metaverso.
¿Qué significa todo esto para nosotros?
Significa que la web va a volver a ser, otra vez, un lugar apasionante.
Va a ser súper emocionante a medida que se transforme
en un mundo profundo y altamente interactivo,
con gráficos, poder computacional y pocos secretos,
este tipo de aplicaciones y posibilidades
van a inyectar un flujo de contenidos “ricos” en sus vidas.
De este modo, la iniciativa Virtual Earth y otras similares
apuntan hacia acrecentar nuestra actual metáfora de búsqueda.
Si lo piensan, estamos muy limitados al buscar en la web,
recordando las URLs y guardándolas en favoritos.
Cuando hacemos una búsqueda confiamos en los rankings de relevancia,
en la concordancia de términos y la indexación,
pero… ¡también queremos usar el cerebro!
Queremos navegar, explorar, descubrir información.
Y para eso hacerlo te ponemos, como usuario, en el asiento del conductor.
Necesitamos una mayor cooperación entre la red, la computadora y tú.
Entonces, ¿que mejor manera de colocarte en el asiento del conductor
que ponerte en el mundo real, en el que interactúas a diario?
¿Por qué no capitalizar las lecciones aprendidas durante toda una vida?
Bueno, Virtual Earth trata, ya verán, de iniciar,
de crear la primera representación digital, exhaustiva, del mundo entero.
Queremos mezclar todo tipo de datos.
Etiquetarlos, clasificarlos. Metadatos. Poner a la comunidad a agregarle profundidad local
-- perspectiva global, conocimiento local.
Así que, pensando en este problema
es una tarea colosal: ¿por dónde empezar?
Bien, recolectamos datos satelitales, desde aviones,
y vehículos terrestres, sobre la gente.
Este proceso representa un problema de ingeniería,
un problema mecánico, un problema logístico, un problema operativo.
Aquí hay un ejemplo de nuestra cámara aérea.
Es pancromática. En realidad consiste de cuatro conos cromáticos.
Además, es multiespectral.
Recolectamos cuatro gigabits de datos por segundo.
¿Pueden hacerse una idea del aluvión de datos de descarga?
Eso equivale a la capacidad de una constelación de 12 satélites en la más alta definición.
Volamos estos aviones a 1500 metros de altura;
podrán observar la cámara al frente. Recolectamos desde múltiples puntos de vista,
puntos panorámicos, ángulos, texturas. Recolectamos todos esos datos.
Nos sentamos aquí -- ustedes saben, al nivel de cualquier vehículo terrestre, desde donde los humanos ven --
¿Qué es lo que una persona ve? Necesitamos capturar eso bien de cerca
para establecer el tipo de experiencia de primera mano.
Apuesto que muchos de ustedes han visto los comerciales de Apple
que toman el pelo a la PC, por supuesto, con brillantez y simplicidad.
Bien, hay un secreto que pocos conocen.
¿Vieron el comercial del tipo de la cámara web?
El del pobre tipo de la PC que tiene la cámara web en la cabeza pegada con cinta adhesiva.
Bueno, pocos saben que en realidad su hermano trabaja en el equipo de Virtual Earth.
(Risas). De modo que aquí hay algo de rivalidad familiar.
Pero déjenme decirles que esto no condiciona su trabajo.
Pensamos que de esta tecnología pueden surgir muchas cosas buenas.
Esto fue después de Katrina. Fuimos la primera flota de aeronaves comerciales
en sobrevolar la zona de impacto del desastre.
Sobrevolamos el área, tomamos imágenes, enviamos personas, tomamos fotografías de los interiores,
de las áreas del desastre. Ayudamos con los primeros auxilios, la búsqueda y el rescate.
A menudo Virtual Earth era la primera herramienta con la que la gente veía lo que había sucedido en sus casas.
Lo pusimos a disposición en la Web de forma gratuita;
era obviamente nuestra oportunidad de contribuir con la causa.
Si pensamos cómo se une todo esto,
todo es cuestión de software, algoritmos y matemática.
Capturamos estas imágenes, pero para construir los modelos 3D
necesitamos hacer geoposicionamiento. Tenemos que georegistrar las imágenes.
Hay que corregir las distorsiones y encontrar los puntos de contacto.
Extraer la geometría contenida en las imágenes.
Este proceso requiere mucho cálculo.
De hecho, siempre se hacía a mano.
En Hollywood gastaban millones de dólares para modelar un pequeño pasillo urbano
en una película porque tenían que hacerlo de forma manual.
Conducían por las calles con rayos láser llamados LIDAR.
Recolectaban información con fotos; construían manualmente cada edificio.
Nosotros hacemos todo con software, algoritmos y matemática.
Una secuencia altamente automatizada de comandos crea estas ciudades.
Esto cuesta una parte ínfima del costo total de construcción de estas ciudades.
es así como podremos redimensionarlo haciendo de esta realidad un sueño.
Pensamos en la interfaz de usuario.
¿Qué significa mirarla desde perspectivas múltiples?
¿una ortofoto? ¿un nadir? ¿Cómo compatibilizar la fidelidad de las imágenes
con la fluidez del modelo?
Voy a cerrar con algo...
que no había mostrado hasta ahora, un “detrás de la escena” del laboratorio de Virtual Earth.
Estamos haciendo esta captura que a la gente le gusta mucho
la captura a vuelo de pájaro. Son datos de alta resolución.
Hemos descubierto que aprecian la fluidez del modelo 3D.
Un niño puede navegarlo con el control remoto de una Xbox o de un videojuego.
Aquí estamos intentando tomar la imagen y proyectarla en un modelo espacial 3D.
Pueden ver todo tipo de resolución. Desde aquí puedo tomar lentamente vistas panorámicas de la imagen.
Puedo obtener la próxima imagen, mezclar y hacer transiciones.
Y al hacerlo no pierdo el detalle original. De hecho, podría estar grabando la historia.
La frescura, la capacidad. Puedo rotar esta imagen.
Puedo verla desde múltiples ángulos y puntos de vista.
En definitiva estamos intentando crear un mundo virtual.
Esperamos poder hacer de la computación un modelo de usuario que les resulte familiar
y que contenga contribuciones de todos ustedes, provenientes de cualquier parte.
Muchas gracias por su tiempo.
(Aplausos)